[Music]
well it's interesting before we even get
into like your amazing work first of all
I'm very excited that you're here thank
you for coming yeah we're dealing with
potential fires in the area so that
induces a little bit of stress which we
could move yeah I'm good but so far I
think we're in the clear and I think
we'll be alright for the next couple
hours but we're keeping a watch on it
your relationship with your sister is
super interesting and when I think of
the work that you do and that and the
work that your sister does it sort of
feels like the Whiskey sisters wait tell
me what that is oh you don't know so
these three women who are all like super
accomplished I went to school at
Stanford with Janet and she's a she's a
doctor at UCSF who specializes in
telomeres like super accomplished and
the CEO of YouTube and the CEO of
23andme are the other two and they have
this amazing mother
ester they went to Palo Alto High School
and she's become like a guru of
education because like how did you raise
these three incredible daughters I get
that question a lot yeah so how do you
feel that or how do you think on that I
always tell people so I think the way
you end up with daughters like me and my
sister the the best thing they did is
they encouraged us with anything we had
any interest or aptitude at in often
very unusual ways so like my sister and
I had very creative interests and
instead of just doing it in like a small
way they'd find a way to let us do it in
a big way so I remember my sister got
really interested in this TV show when
we were in middle school and was just
when prodigy was coming out like you
could connect to the Internet and
somehow my parents encouraged her to
develop a newsletter for the entire
country based on the show home front and
so she was like producing a newsletter
and finding other fans on prodigy and
sending it out and we were always doing
that sort of thing it was like oh you're
interested in this well like don't just
sit and watch the TV show like what's
the craziest version that you could
engage with this even as a kid so we
were always doing these creative
projects and I often feel like even when
her interests were not
super consistent with my parents values
because they were both teachers like I
was really interested in fashion design
for a while and I think that made my mom
like double roll her eyes but she still
let me take classes at a Fashion Design
Institute when I was in high school so I
think like that's because you know we
could have probably turned out to be
fairly successful at whatever we did but
we're both doing really weird things
with our lives like non-traditional
paths
yeah it's almost like a homeschool
technique where you look at what the
person the young person is interested in
and you just kind of leverage that or
like put a lot of investment into trying
to channel that interest into learning
experiences are a little bit more
broader actually that's like my mother's
great gift as an educator so she was a
classroom educator she taught everything
from kindergarten to late middle school
and her secret the reason parents loved
her is she would find out what kids were
obsessed with or what their talents were
and find ways like really bring it out
of them even students that other
teachers thought were problem students
and so I feel like we just we got 18
years of that yeah we need more of that
do you do that with your students um I
it's gotta be harder you're lecturing so
it's different right my approach to
teaching because I do a lot of teaching
and I do mentoring a non-academic kind
of mentoring I am always looking for the
good in that person that you can tell
they want it to be true of them but
maybe it's not fully developed yet and
it try to be a mirror for it so if I see
that seed to make it the first thing I
provide feedback on so that they know
that that is part of who they are and
it's in them and find ways to amplify
that good and I feel like that's sort of
the same yeah
it's empowering and the person must feel
like I'm okay they're being seen right
and there's nothing more encouraging
than having that sensation or that
feeling yeah very cool all right well
you've done all this amazing work in the
fields of everything from compassion to
willpower to stress which we can talk
about all of that but it I feel like
you're now synergizing everything that
you've learned in those other fields and
channeling into this this world of
movement it seems like an obvious next
step but how did how did like your
interest in exercise and movement come
about yeah it's actually the opposite of
like the synthesis or the next step this
is who I really am and I think all of
the work that people know me for is sort
of like it's a it's a part of who I am
that I'm really interested in it's like
a class that I taught the science of
willpower or the science of stress but I
have been in love with movement and
exercise since I was a little girl and
I've been teaching group fitness for 20
years so it's more like finally now that
I've like solve some other problems for
people got that willpower under control
we're getting good at stress now I get
to convince people to dance or run or
swim or to really bring their whole body
into the pursuit of happiness and
connection how come it wasn't the first
book that I don't think well so okay so
my approach to publishing has always
been I wait for someone to ask me what
book I should write Nexo my first book
was yoga for pain relief and it was
because a publisher literally sent me a
letter in the mail that said we've seen
the work you're doing on yoga at various
conferences and in research um do you
want to write a book about it no it's
like okay and then I was teaching this
class called the science of willpower
that was getting a lot of notoriety
because it was so popular and then
agents started saying you should write a
book about this so I said okay and then
I gave that TED talk you should write a
book about that okay and so this was the
first book where I said this is the book
that I really like nobody was asked in
the book that I probably wanted to write
my whole life and finally now maybe
having some sort of platform where
people will be interested in finding out
why yeah exercise is so critical to
mental health yeah well there's an
expectation with any book of this ilk
that it's gonna be this step-by-step
how-to and and you said or you've
written that that was your expectation
going into this and then it became
another thing altogether so explain that
a little bit yeah I thought what it
happened for two reasons one is I
thought I was going to write this sort
of self-help book that was like you
think you don't like to move you think
you don't enjoy it I believe that
there's a form of movement meant for
everyone
and no matter what body you're in or no
matter what your past experience is
there's probably a way that moving your
body will give you access to something
that you want whether it's social
connection or hope a different sense of
yourself and so I thought well I'll just
write the book that helps people figure
out what that is and when I wrote the
proposal my editor really didn't like it
she's not really a self-help kind of
person so the one reason that it's not
that is because she actually encouraged
me like what's the what's the big idea
here and for me the equivalent of what's
the big idea is really what's the
feeling here and so I feel like she gave
me permission to think not just you know
here's how to make your work out more
meaningful and enjoyable but to really
think about like what is the feeling
that I have when I Marvel about how the
body is so is almost designed to help us
find happiness and meaning through
movement what's that feeling that sense
of wonder and on what does it tell us
about being human and when I had
permission to think in that way I feel
like it opened me up to a different type
of story as well from and I feel like
that was the other piece of how it
turned out not to be necessarily a
step-by-step self-help book is when I
started talking to people about movement
one of things I realized is when you
talk to people who have found meaning
and movement that they become this
version of themselves when they're
telling you their story that is this
amazing mixture of both incredible
vulnerability and strength that somehow
they both emerge and you can see like
this full human in this tremendous glory
and beauty and I felt like I need to do
that justice when people were telling me
their stories and like they were crying
and I was crying I was like I don't
think this is this is gonna be some sort
of cheesy self-help book that I needed
to write a book that somehow honored the
versions of themselves they were sharing
with me you know were talking about how
does you know right growing change your
life yeah yeah yeah no I get it I mean
you're at listen you're speaking my
language you don't have to tell me like
I don't you know it's funny cuz when I
read the book I'm thinking I'm not
really the audience for this because I'm
already sold like you're selling me
about
a package of goods that I bought a long
time ago but I learned a lot about a lot
of stuff that I didn't know about and I
think what what you're uniquely
qualified to do is take these ideas
which can very quickly you know descend
into the world of woowoo like if I was
gonna write this book it would be crazy
woowoo but you can take this version
well I mean you could first of all thank
you for putting me in the book it was a
woowoo we quote you know I look at it as
as you know movement is is part and
parcel of what it means to be human it's
also a journey that we can embark upon
that will that will you know kind of
catalyze this trajectory towards
wholeness spiritually emotionally
mentally of course physically so you
sound like the one of the reverence that
I talk to that's like almost exactly
what she said about movement - yeah and
it's a beautiful thing and I think it is
important that that every human being
discover their version of movement that
is compatible with who they are but it's
a very powerful kind of Archimedes lever
for personal growth across the board but
to get back to my point you're you're
able to because of your pedigree you can
inject it with the science the
anthropology the psychology and all of
these interesting anecdotes that come
from you know a wide spectrum of
different types of people from athletes
themselves to the you know the
researchers and you know diving into the
research itself yes and and I think that
makes it emotionally engaging for the
reader and you're always changing gears
but yeah it's about it's about
self-discovery as much as anything else
but it's also about it's about community
and cooperation and all these other
ideas how is you kind of bring into it I
think that was the biggest surprise for
me because if you look at the thread of
my past work I I keep coming back to
this idea that like nothing is a
do-it-yourself project like every
problem that I've tried to solve
I'm always pointing people in the
direction of make it social do it in
community get support you know let
social connection be your primary
response to stress but somehow like even
though I'd live
and I have experienced so much of a
sense of community and belonging through
movement and teaching movement I somehow
didn't think that was going to be the
primary lens for this book
you know sinking oh you know endorphin
rush and how it changes the brain and I
didn't understand how fully the joy of
movement is the joy of connection and
how fully integrated in our brains and
our bodies the biology of movement is
with the biology of social connection
that was a huge surprise for me
and I was like I was so happy that that
emerged as a theme yeah how do you
square that with the kind of experience
that that like like that's certainly
true but there's also that you talk
about like I forget what you call it
like green exercise or green where
you're connecting with nature like a big
part of just speaking from my own
experience like a big part of this for
me is time spent alone like out in
nature and actually don't do very much
training with other people like I find
that stressful sometimes I have to be at
this certain place with these people and
it's organized and like I just want to
go out the door and like it's my quiet
time and it's my you know it's an active
meditation I decompress I breathe the
air I pay attention to my breath and
things like that that that aren't really
you know that that don't really line up
with cooperation and kind of group
participation aspect of it so in that
chapter one of the things I wrote about
that really intrigued me is this idea
that to become great as a species human
beings needed to learn these social
skills cooperation and thinking about
other people and we have this sort of
default state that allows us to
constantly be thinking about ourselves
in relationship with other people
and that we also needed to develop these
skills that allow us to be in nature and
to connect with nature and to experience
self transcendence in nature that is so
different internally from that version
of us as humans that are always thinking
about other people on how do we get
along and belong and one of the things
that I realized in talking to people who
really find moving
in nature healing therapeutic inspiring
is that the sort of the the relief from
suffering that they need is more that
aspect of being human that is so much
like what many people experience when
they meditate or they go on solo treks
and journeys there's a version of being
by yourself that is also at the same
time connected to something bigger than
yourself but you're free from those
social roles and and all of that angst
or that just the the pressure the
busyness that comes from being a social
creature and I was so fascinated by that
and I talked to so many people who have
that experience and it's in contrast to
me I think like my my essential nature
is to be alone and withdraw and the the
thing that I need is something to pull
me out yeah of that like great comfort
that I have just being in here and by
myself and almost like I could be on
retreat all the time and so the thing
that I need that's therapeutic is no you
need to be in a room with other people
and you need to connect and you need to
like really touch that aspect of your
human nature yeah and so I think that
you know people are probably with
movement it's always about finding the
thing that's that's your medicine and
you know movement helps us access so
many different parts of our human nature
that are useful or that are meaningful
and the nature is one of those yeah I
mean I can relate to that
you're a self-avowed introvert I
certainly consider myself the same and
so and and you know building on that I'm
also you know a long time in recovery
and there's this very alcoholic tendency
to want to isolate you know and I can
and I can mask that tendency with
endurance sports you know when I know
like I probably should I am better and
happier and more fulfilled when I'm in
groups of people but I have to really
compel myself to do that but I can say
well you know I trail run by myself or
whatever but I do know that when I do
participate in those group endeavors
that it is like incredibly fulfilling
but I really have to marshal a lot of
energy to do that and thinking of you
know your career your with students all
the time you're teaching all the time
and you're teaching these group these
group classes I would imagine that
you would also you know the counterpoint
to that would be that you would need
some solace that involve some kind of
movement yeah and I do um I do move on
my own I mean there was a lot of things
that I do that are you know it's sort of
my own personal practice teaching
academic classes is very different
energetically for me than teaching
movement classes I am I get more energy
from teaching movement classes
whereas I find giving talks or teaching
academic classes training definitely
draining I often feel like I've been run
over by a bus there's a sense of the
energy flow is much more from me outward
and and really just working hard to try
to create an experience of value for
others when I'm teaching like a dance
class I don't know the music gives me so
much energy and to see other people
moving in to be it feels more like I'm
co-creating an experience so I didn't
bring that into the classroom somehow
sometimes but even I mean in so many
different forms of teaching I do you
know whether I'm leading like a
meditation retreat or giving a lecture
there's no other form of teaching and I
think it's again it's just part of how
I'm wired that there's something about
moving to music and using my body and
not talking right talking is a totally
different form of being with a group
than mirroring and and sort of leading
through the body that I find that that
the teaching the movement is is part of
that right so when this goes up it will
be a brand spankin new year so the idea
of new year's resolutions and kind of
creating a trajectory for for you know
new year new you is on everybody's minds
and I have a fan I know some people are
very cynical yeah I'm like why not it's
the beginning of a new year well let's
like unpack that a little bit because I
think it also brings in the work that
you've done in these other areas right
like people are thinking about willpower
do I have the willpower to you know set
this goal and actually follow through
this time even though I you know the
past five years I keep failing and
you know perhaps somebody's you know
resolution is to reduce the stress in
their lives like how do we how do we
think about new year's resolutions in a
healthy way and create a strategy that's
actually effective rather than
self-defeating you know two or three
weeks in when we abandon hope so I'm a
big fan of doing some serious reflection
like not just picking a behavior like
drink more water because you saw it
somewhere as like a healthy habit and I
often will encourage people to ask
themselves some set of questions like if
you were to project yourself to next New
Year's Day a year from now and you were
going to look back and be really
grateful that you made one change what
can you imagine you could do in the next
year that that future you is gonna be so
grateful like it's going to have
improved your vitality your health your
relationships moved you forward in some
way that is consistent with the vision
you have for your life maybe that
question or you know is there a kind of
suffering in your life right now that
you're just ready to be free from and
what might that look like
or is there for movement I would
particularly ask people is there a type
of joy that you are seeking in your life
right now forget if you even think it's
connected to movement but something like
social connection or hope or mastery
progress adventure playfulness
creativity because there's some kind of
joy that you're missing that you just
know if you had more of it in your life
that would be a greater change to ask
that sort of question and then when you
have that kind of vision of what you
want then to get concrete and say can I
think of some choice or behavior that
feels like it's really consistent with
that even if I'm not entirely sure you
know what it's gonna look like a year
from now but I think that the New Year's
resolve I often will choose a word for
myself that's like how I want to
approach the year or what I want more of
in that year but if you set that kind of
framework then it allows you to both
experiment with behaviors like is this
getting me closer to that type of joy or
is this actually reducing my suffering
or just increasing the suffering and to
change your approach as you go through
the year
while you keep Mike yeah I mean
essentially what you're saying is is
getting clarity on what your y is right
you talk about like the big y like what
is the why behind this rather than the
behavior that you're trying to modify
like what's behind that is how do you
know what the behavior is if you don't
know what your want is and in the
willpower instinct I talk about it is
want power but this is actually a
strength many people need to develop the
ability to know what matters most to you
the roles the relationships the values
yeah values what are your values and if
you're clear on that it gets so much
easier to figure out what behaviors to
try to change and to pay attention to
the actual consequences of whatever this
thing is you're trying to control I feel
like way too often people think about
self-control as like the key thing that
they target on like what do I feel out
of control with that I'm going to force
myself to control but that's not always
the thing that's gonna have the biggest
impact on your well-being you know you
may have a bad habit in one area that's
really not destroying your life in any
meaningful way but it's something that
you are you're always judgmental about
and I feel like people often go in that
direction they're like what can I
control now as opposed to what I really
care about
yeah and that's that's not a sustainable
energy source right ultimately you can
sustain the process of it as it you can
sustain the process of like self blame
and hate and value change and you'll
start having an unhealthy amount of
chronic stress I would imagine yeah yeah
but but kind of flipping that to look
through a different prism like the
aspirational prism of like the person
you want to become so if you take like
weight loss for example big one
obviously rather than thinking like I
got to lose weight the Y would be like I
want to feel good in my body or I want
to be healthy or I want to look in the
mirror and feel good about my appearance
or whatever that whatever what is the
value that's attached to that and then
I'm gathering what you're what you're
really saying is then identifying the
behaviors that you can do like the Wills
that you can implement that lead you in
that direction as opposed to focusing on
the
we'll not like the things that you're
gonna avoid and also the things you
can't control like you mean wait we
think it's something that you can choose
but you can't actually choose to wake up
you know in a month and weigh less or
weigh more it's a lot easier to choose
things that will reliably give you more
energy improve your health and weight
may or may not be a consequence of that
I think a lot of it is defining the the
thing that actually you're pretty clear
you can choose and get that consequence
whether it's having more energy being
healthier feeling better about yourself
that you can actually work directly with
that rather than setting these goals you
know you if it were something with money
for example rather than say I want to
have this amount of money in the bank
maybe what you want is a feeling of
financial freedom more security and that
there are choices you can make every day
that move you in that direction even if
you can't guarantee at the end of the
year I'm gonna have this amount of money
in my bank account or how to reduce my
debt this much so it's it's not only
choosing things that you can say yes to
but that things that you're not setting
yourself up to have like a success that
you can check off or not that almost it
pulls our attention away from the daily
benefits we get when we're actually
engaging in behaviors that are good for
us I think the problem with a lot of
this is that those tiny imperceptible
actions that you take every day that
move you in that direction just aren't
sexy you know you're not getting the
likes on Instagram for them they don't
seem necessarily to be moving you
forward in a tangible you know from an
external point of view I think they're
super important and they create momentum
and there's an internal I think shift
that occurs with them
but I think a lot of people struggle
with that because they're so focused on
the end goal that they don't learn how
to fall in love with the process or the
journey of getting there I think this is
where mindfulness comes in because again
if you've chosen something that really
has the power to transform your
well-being in some way you will notice
it as it's happening if you're paying
attention and that becomes a much more
motivating reward than the initial
reward that's a lot easier to track like
I did this today I didn't do this today
or you know some change some number that
you're tracking but you do have to learn
to pay attention it's almost a process
of self trust that you you know you say
at the end of the day how do I feel
about what I did
maybe there's a sense of pride a sense
of celebration for whatever steps you
took but pretty quickly over time you
should notice the direct benefits of
what you're doing and again this can be
like a reality check it's almost like an
integrity check it is much easier to
choose something where you can define it
and check it off and keep track and like
get on some you know streak of good
behavior but if that's not the right
behavior for you and what you need at
this time in your life all you're doing
is is sort of giving yourself something
else to be distracted by these sort of
like the short-term wins and feel good
so you know mindfulness is a big part of
that because I feel like a lot of my
behaviors change for the better when I
got very serious about yoga practice
because it became so much easier to
notice the effects of my choices in
everyday life I started to find it
really hard to do things that were
inconsistent with my values like to be
dishonest or to eat food that made me
feel hungover afterward huh I just
couldn't do it because it was so clear I
just I could just see the consequence as
it was unfolding and I I think a lot of
that has to do with the quality of
attention you train in practices like
yoga or meditation yeah I think that
level of self-awareness is super
important and I feel like people a
common mistake that a lot of people make
is they want to skip that part and they
want to go right to the goal and I see a
lot of people who I'm not convinced are
setting the right goal for themselves
they're doing because they feel like
that's what they should be doing but
there isn't enough introspection into
whether that really aligns with the the
values you know that they're that they
aspire to you know embody in their lives
and short of mindfulness practices or
yoga or movement as you talked about in
the book you know these are all vehicles
for unlocking that you know or deepening
that level of self connection I think
you're just you're a ping-pong ball
you're reacting to your environment or
to social expectations of you know what
you think you are supposed to be
yeah yeah so what are what are some of
the common pitfalls that derail people
when it comes to you know these New
Year's resolutions that you're such a
fan of yeah well one thing is choosing
something that is something you the idea
that you have to finish resolutions you
made in the past because they're
unresolved and so often all you know I
used to do a lot of press around
willpower at New Year's and almost every
time people I'd be interviewing I say
what's your new year's resolution and
they'd say something that was what they
had failed at the last few years and
they were gonna try again and I'd ask
okay well what benefit is this gonna
bring to your life and they'd be like I
don't know and then I'd be like well
what would really like what would bring
you more joy in your life and I still
remember this one interview where she's
like oh I wish I had time to play the
piano again it's like she lit up and it
was a whole different person like why is
that not your New Year's resolution so
that that first pitfall which we've
talked about um another pitfall is
probably the relationship that you have
with yourself as you're changing you
know we need to if again if it's a
really good change and it's not
something that's easy like as soon as
you decide you're going to do it you do
it we know that the trajectory is going
to include setbacks and obstacles and
mistakes and I think people have the
sense that once you've made the vow it
should be done and there's never going
to be the day where you slide back and
there's never going to be the day where
you're the worst version of yourself and
you're so exhausted you do the opposite
of everything you value wouldn't do and
so we need some kind of vision about
what the process of change looks like
and to understand that any really
meaningful change is going to include
that day where you feel like giving art
yeah be people people don't recognize
the fact that every success comes with a
lot of failures and I think we set
ourselves up such that if we meet that
obstacle and fall short that we're not
good enough or you know that we abandon
hope rather than just recognizing that's
part of the process one of the things I
often encourage people to do who feel
like they don't know what to do when
they hit that kind of setback is to
imagine okay imagine this is the end of
the story and we actually
the outcome that you have accomplished
this goal or made this change some point
in the future and you're telling the
story of how it happened I want you to
look back at today and what was the
turning point how was this a turning
point what was the next thing you did
that moved you in that story toward
change then just do that right so
basically forecasting your idealized
self yeah
and understanding that that what you are
stuck in the middle of now is a part of
that journey uh-huh
that it doesn't it doesn't reveal that
you are unable to continue on this path
yeah in my experience momentum police
such a key role in all of this I mean
we've all had that experience where
we're doing really well at something and
then some intervening unexpected life
event occurs that throws us off our
schedule and then it becomes so
difficult to kind of get back on the
horse whether it's going to the gym or
whatever it is I'm wondering if there's
any science behind the power of momentum
and how that you know kind of operates
on our psyche yeah I actually can work
in both ways so some people are derailed
by momentum because they feel so good
about their progress they're like hey I
can like take a break right so some
people fall into that trap or if you're
a self-sabotage er yeah now's a good
time to blow everything up I think you
know one reason why I often talk about
the importance of celebrating successes
or appreciating effort because it
changes in part the way you feel about
yourself as someone who is engaged in
this difficult task so I think momentum
works because then you can tell a story
about yourself that is really empowering
and gives you the positive energy to
keep going it's like fuel and I think
that that as soon as we experienced a
setback often one of the reasons it's so
dear ailing is we start to tell a story
about ourselves rather than a story
about today like we don't have that
ability to be compassionate and say okay
you just went through a health crisis or
you just had to deal with this other
thing in your life of course your energy
went there and there was less energy
available for this other project you've
been working on instead we start to tell
story about ourselves or our lives that
feels fixed
this is never gonna happen or I'm not
capable of this it's sort of like when
values compete for your attention and
resources right like it's not just that
we have one value that we're aspiring to
embody there's multiple values right and
sometimes they come into conflict and
that's okay it can change your
priorities moment to moment and
particularly when you do it with the
sense of agency and autonomy like you
know what I said I was going to be
dedicated this year to improving my
health and then I had to step into this
caregiver role and right now I'm
fulfilling that role and it's meaningful
and it's stressful it's difficult and
I've slid back a little bit on this
other thing like I think we should feel
free to fully endorse that kind of shift
and and really honor any any connection
between what we're doing and what we
care about yeah I tend to beat myself up
yeah you're not alone well a lot of
people's new year's resolutions pivot
around movement right and that's what
you're writing about in this new book so
let's talk about movement I'm super
interested in hearing your thoughts that
you explore in this book about what's
happening with us psychologically and
biochemically when we move our bodies
well let's start with the biochemical if
some of this is so fascinating can I
explain the whole molecule thing yeah I
was trust me I wrote that down like
these whole these these hormones are
recent the Myo kinds super interesting
um I know when I found so I came across
this paper I think it was maybe 2016
paper where the scientist talked about
this research and they just sort of
throw out the term hope molecules and I
remember circling it I think I like said
to my husband oh my gosh you're not
gonna believe this term it encapsulates
so much about why movement is amazing
and I feel like nobody else is using
this term it's just in this one paper
I'm gonna ensure the scientist I've used
it again but let me explain what it is
so this is the idea that our muscles are
like an endocrine organ and that when
you contract your muscles in any type of
movement they are secreting chemicals
into your bloodstream that are really
good
for every system of your body I mean
they're great for your heart health and
your immune function and some of them
can kill cancer cells you know all the
stuff we know exercise is good for
without a big part of these these
proteins are chemicals that are being
released by your muscles which are
called my oak ions
they have profound effects on the brain
so you go for a walk or a run or you
lift weights and your muscles contract
and they secrete these proteins into
your bloodstream they travel to your
brain they cross the blood-brain barrier
and in your brain they can act as an
anti depressant like Ireson can they can
make your brain more resilient to stress
they increase motivation they help you
learn from experience and the only way
you get these chemicals is by using your
muscles it's like this is part of how we
become our best selves is we have to use
our muscles and then the scientists call
them hope molecules because in this one
study they found that exercise could
protect rodents from experiencing
depression and post-traumatic stress
disorder if you severely traumatized
them so this idea that that these
molecules are giving you hope even in
vertical times so it's not innately
human that's right it's not innately
humans it is and other mammals it's in
well it's so I don't know how many
species this has been studied in it's
like in in this field you tend to go
from mice and rats to humans I think not
a lot in the middle but it should be
pointed out that rodents are very social
species and that's one of the reasons
why they're they can be really great
models for human behavior because they
look a lot like us and some of the very
basic social and psychological ways so
extrapolating on that idea like what do
you like what do you make of that like
what does that mean well first of all a
very practical level it means when I go
for a walk or I exercise I will
literally say to myself you were giving
yourself an intravenous dose of hope
like I think this is how we should frame
movement that that it's something you
can choose to do to really powerfully
influenced your mental health and your
resilience and every time you move
you're doing that I think to know that
to like look at your own muscles and be
able to say thank you legs you're tired
now that was hard work
but like legs your you are a pharmacy
that of antidepressants and resilience
and hope then sort of thinking like in a
more philosophical way again one of the
things that I feel like the anthropology
and the science is pointing to is that
movement is how your brain knows you are
alive and engaged in life and when you
move on a regular basis your brain
basically says I guess we have to be the
best version of ourselves because we're
in this thing called life and so you
know you mentioned some other things too
like when you exercise you see increased
levels of neurotransmitters that tend to
increase our willingness to cooperate
and the pleasure we get from connecting
with others that give us hope and
courage I mean even that lactic acid
that that metabolic byproduct of
exercise that lactic acid seems to have
an anti-anxiety and antidepressant
effect right this is a crazy stuff it's
not just an endorphin rush it's like at
every level of our biology when we move
our brain is like I guess we have to do
this thing called life and so you know
for people like me who've struggled with
anxiety or depression this idea that you
can convince your brain to want to fully
engage with life in a brave way or in a
hopeful way through movement is so
phenomenal how does that measure up
against what we think about anecdotally
as the runner's high yeah just kind of
how you open the book I opened it was
funny because I'm not a runner but my
husband is a runner and my sisters he's
a serious runner you did a triathlon
though didn't you me yeah you said you
were in the book you said you were think
you and your husband were thinking about
doing a trial my husband oh I was
thinking about saying yes go for it the
only thing I've ever participated in was
a Dance Marathon okay um yeah so I'm not
a runner and so part of my interest in
exploring the science was um like to
really understand why people I love love
this thing that's not my movement and so
I started to dig into that like what is
the runner's high and I came across this
research that in part the runner's high
is fueled by endocannabinoids not only
endorphins
and then endocannabinoids as a
neurotransmitter system is really about
reducing anxiety and making us sort of
more bold and more courageous as well as
more social and that we we get more of
that warm glow from any kind of social
interaction and the anthropologists who
think about the runner's high there's
this idea that the reason we have the
runner's high is so that you know you
know back hundreds of thousands of years
ago that we could sustain hunting and
gathering but that also hunting and
gathering was part of being a social
species and being a tribe and so that
this sort of runner's high
not only allowed early humans to go out
and do the hard work of gathering food
but maybe was even helping them be the
version of themselves that wouldn't be
like I caught this big animal it's mine
good luck to the rest of you I hope you
don't starve that the runner's high was
actually making it easier to be a
cooperative species that's super
interest it is and then you know one
thing I didn't put in the book cuz I am
Not sure the research is fully there but
a lot of people I talk to think oxytocin
is also part of this and there's the
research just is not as robust right now
but oxytocin you know as a neuro hormone
that helps us bond with others and also
that makes us remember events more
positively than maybe they were when
they actually transpired some some
researchers think this is why people
will run ultra marathons more than once
yeah isn't that there's so much oxytocin
release that somehow at a distance it
seems better than maybe it actually was
at the worst moment so that that great
his coloring your memory but it was just
like oxytocin and orphans
endocannabinoids that the biochemistry
of a runner's high is priming us to not
only feel good while you're moving which
is I think how we often think about it
like it's a gimmick to trick you into
exercising but that what it might
actually be is your your brain being
like okay now we have to be this version
of ourselves who can persist and can
cooperate with others and that changes
who we are after a workout we can be a
different version of ourselves well we
have so we have this soup of all these
you know feel-good chemical
swirling around in our bodies as a
result of this kind of movement which
brings up something that I have to field
all the time which which is this idea
that because I'm a recovering alcoholic
that I'm just I've channeled all my
addictive tendencies into endurance
exercise and this is just an extension
of you know rich role the addict and I'm
pursuing this runner's high in a very
unhealthy way and that's why you see so
many people in recovery in the endurance
and ultra endurance communities that
they're just basically perpetuating this
unhealthy behavior pattern yeah so I
mean you can tell from my book that's
not my take on it but I know yes well I
think you would rot you addressed it
really beautifully you know I have my
friend Mishka
who's been on the podcast a bunch of
times he he just dismisses it with like
this quippy thing that he says which is
putting you know taking the dirt the
drink of the drug was always the easy
choice and the way out putting on the
running shoes is hard you know it's like
it's a vehicle for self-improvement
it's it's it's a difficult thing that
you grapple with that that leads to
greater self-efficacy and all these you
know fantastic things so he you know it
and I see it similarly like I first of
all I acknowledge that I'm like yeah
there probably is a part of me that that
is doing this for that reason like I
think it would be profound to rated for
me to say no that's not the case at all
but is it making my life better or is it
making it worse
you know and it's clearly making my life
better it can be out of balance I've
seen that with a lot of people who get
obsessed with their training and then
they're you know their marriage is
dissolved and you know all kinds of
terrible things happen so I have to be
aware of that and balance it
appropriately but when I do do that
everything in my life has actually
improved as a result yeah I think that's
basically my take on it too and I was
really fascinated by the research on the
neuroscience of addiction and exercise
and how they're really similar in some
ways but really different in ways that
matter and that like exercise almost by
hijack
some of the mechanisms of addiction make
you really want it and like it and crave
it but that it's changing your brain in
the exact opposite ways as most
substances of abuse that people get
addicted to so that you're more open to
other pleasures that you're better able
to connect with other people and I think
that like that's one of the most
important distinctions that that most
people who have dealt with some other
type of addiction will we'll talk about
when they talk about the difference that
they might feel addicted to movement and
sometimes people a lot of people feel
dependent on it I'm totally dependent on
it but you know what diabetics are
dependent on insulin I'm very happy to
be dependent on dependent to and
sleeping exactly but that most people
will will point out that when you become
dependent on movement it often enhances
your ability to also pursue other goals
and to be a version of yourself in
relationships that you actually are
proud to be that version of yourself and
that's that's pretty different from
other addictions yeah part of your
exploration is trying to determine the
genetic markers for people that are you
know I know that's dependent and one of
the things you do is you you do the
23andme thing and you get all this data
back and you're trying to figure out
like where do I
where where where can I identify my
proclivity for being an exercise freak
yeah so I just say a couple things about
this first of all I think it's a really
bad idea to do it yourself why not three
and me guy going in the raw data so my
husband who's a scientist was helping me
try to figure out what you know all
these different ways to work with the
raw data so I don't necessarily
recommend this and the the science
itself is super fledgling so it could
all be bunk basically but I was
interested in doing this because um my
twin sister and I are both totally
hooked on movement we both feel
dependent on it and this emerged very
early in life like I mean I got my first
taste of aerobics when I was seven or
eight and I was like hooked instantly I
can even remember not wanting to go to a
friend's birthday party in fifth grade
because I was gonna miss the exercise
hour that was on like PBS that I wanted
to do and be like oh they're trying to
way which one was more important I guess
maybe
the sign of addiction but so I was
hooked immediately and to see how
important is for both me and my sister I
thought like this must be genetic
because we're identical twins and there
are certain things I mean I very much
believe are genetically determined
because we are so similar in so many
ways and I thought this must be one of
them and when I actually looked at some
of the the markers genetic markers that
have been linked to exercise behavior
and how much you enjoy exercise we
didn't necessarily have all of those but
there are some some bits of DNA that
have been linked to really benefiting
psychologically from movement that is
you are at both increased risk of things
like depression or anxiety disorders or
suicidal thinking but if you exercise
those risks are dramatically reduced or
in other studies you respond better to a
exercise intervention like you have
better psychological outcomes than
people who don't have those genetic
markers and when I looked at those
studies my sister and I had every single
one of them Wow and I just feel like you
know cuz when we were growing up nobody
was in therapy I don't I mean this was
you know decades ago there was nobody
helping me manage my mind when I was a
kid yeah and the idea that both of us
found this thing that helped us deal
with genetic susceptibilities to anxiety
and depression I'm very grateful it's
interesting how the human animal can
root out that thing that will be
curative you know whether it's a you
know it's like they say everybody finds
the drug that they need to quell
whatever it is that they're trying to
deal with somehow that happens and
exercise certainly you know could be
considered you know a healthier version
of that I have no doubt but if I hadn't
found exercise I would have doing
something less fun right exactly and
I've done both but I probably have those
same genetic markers because I wake up
every day and left to my own devices
like going out of moving my body is what
I choose to do I look forward to it I
can't wait to do it the only thing that
gets in the way is
when I have other obligations I have
another value that competes with that
value but I think there's a lot of
people out there who who can read the
book or listen to what you're saying and
they you know they can intellectually
grasp that all the finer points of why
this is a good idea but they lack that
impetus like they look at it as
burdensome or or intimidating or
something that they they just don't
connect with it so a couple things about
this first of all I should say in in my
experience talking to people there are a
lot of late to life movers who just
needed to find the right form of
movement and I don't think we get
exposed to enough diversity of movement
like women or personnel who got in a
boat at a row and had their whole life
thought they had the wrong body type
that they were in athletes but suddenly
they got in a boat with other women and
were rowing and they were like yes my
body was born for this that you know
there's so many forms of movement that
changed the way you feel about yourself
because they they just create a
different narrative about who you are I
talked to so many women who discovered
things like power lifting or CrossFit or
axe throwing we're suddenly the day
we're doing these amazing things with
their bodies and they felt powerful and
it was a side of themselves they'd never
experienced before and if you were to
only like listen till the way that the
media usually talks about exercise it's
all about burning calories right it's
all about what you look like and you can
get pulled into places where instead of
being told like this is what it feels
like to stand in your own strength
you're told now you're burning more
calories so you won't look as hideous as
you looked walking in today I mean like
that is a very different experience and
too often people's movement experiences
have been defined by this obsession with
burning calories and improving your
appearance and making yourself more
acceptable to either yourself or the
judgment of society and it gets very
confusing very quickly and so I'm always
encouraging people like what's the form
of movement if someone were to send you
a YouTube video what's the video you
would watch and be like wow that's
amazing
and what's the version of that that
would fit into your life who's doing
that in a way that's appropriate for the
body you have right now or the you know
who you want to become that it's not
about like getting a tracker that's
going to tell you if you've done enough
yet right there's so much that gets in
the way of finding the movement that
will make you happy
that can make it feel like a chore like
a punishment we have such a limited
perspective on what those options are we
just think about the gym and the
Stairmaster machine and the little LED
readout that tells you calories and time
and while you're watching you know the
news and it's just it's okay to distract
yourself while you're exercising if that
works for you but there are a lot of
forms of movement where the more
attention you pay to what you're doing
actually the more pleasurable it is but
often I think the advice we get is just
get on the treadmill and watch new
Netflix so that you're not really there
and you can get through it but I bet
there's some form of movement where if
you were really there you would have an
amazing experience a sense of yourself
or a connection with others what is the
science and research tell us about
intensity like do we have to suffer and
you know just kill ourselves or okay
well you know like weird you know what
do we have to do to avail ourselves of
these benefits like how you know how
much how often how intense so there are
two ways to think about this one is
minimum dose so that we're not scaring
people off and then also acknowledging
that many of the benefits are probably
enhanced by greater intensity so if
you're looking to simply feel better to
have a mental health benefit to have a
mood boost and energy boosts or even
physical health benefits there is almost
no minimum of what you need to do and
how non intensity to be you know there's
something in the literature called the
feel better effect which is if you are
sedentary you have not moved in a while
and you do a couple of minutes of any
type of movement you will feel better
you'll have more energy you'll be more
hopeful if that's all you ever did and
you did it a couple times a day that
would be so much better than doing
nothing you know we talked about Myo
kinds as long as you're contracting your
muscles you are producing a healthier
set of my own kinds and if
remove so for if anyone is thinking the
barrier is I don't want to do something
insanely intense so I'm gonna do nothing
instead we should take that off the
table at the same time many of the joys
of movement are enhanced by intensity so
for example there's something called
collective joy which is this feeling of
transcendence and connection to others a
kind of euphoria that we feel when we
move in synchrony with other people
particularly we're moving to music and
the research shows that the higher your
heart rate gets when you're doing that
the more intense the euphoria and the
stronger the social bonds research also
suggests that more intense movement more
endurance is going to produce extremely
high levels of Myo kinds that are
probably very protective for your mental
health and your brain when it comes to
your sense of self you know if you do
something you never thought you could do
and in order to get there you had to
have really tough workouts and you had
to like try to lift something heavy and
fail 20 times before you succeeded
that's a certain type of intensity how
you're gonna feel the day that you
finally do it it's probably be more
powerful than if you set a very small
goal for yourself that you could succeed
at the first time you try so there's so
many different ways that intensity I
think amplifies the joys of mastery and
connection and mental health but people
shouldn't think of that as like you said
suffering and killing yourself it's it's
more like I always tell people what's
the most intense form of movement you
can do and still take joy meaning in it
and again if it's the right form of
movement for you probably part of the
workout you'll be like oh my gosh this
is so uncomfortable why did I say I
wanted to do this and then two minutes
later you're gonna be like I feel
amazing right I mean joy can take
different forms I mean it's like you
know if you want to change your life
like sign up for an ultramarathon you
know you will meet yourself in a way you
never have before and there will be a
tremendous amount of suffering but there
is a joyous aspect to that because it's
a journey of self-discovery that you
really can't replicate in any other way
in your life and we're so afraid of
that level of discomfort but I think our
own thing I mean it's not you have like
I was so delighted that you I mean you
basically have like an entire chapter on
the world of ultra under I was so that
chapter took the longest for me to write
I was revising that like a year after
the manuscript was submitted because
it's so different from my like my own
core forms of movement or yoga and dance
and it it's just I knew it was very
different than the ultra world and I had
to keep talking to people and watching
videos of events and reading memoirs to
feel like I could actually understand it
in a way that was deeper than my initial
impressions of it and I learned so much
about that that's sport in that world
and I was so I found it very moving to
to try to pay attention to that world in
a way that really goes against like many
people who aren't ultra athletes
probably had the same initial response I
had like oh my god why do you need to
practice suffering I'm already suffering
enough like I don't I don't really need
to do it in in that form but then I will
yes no go ahead so I want to interrupt
you but I was the the thing that made
the biggest shift for me was when I
started watching videos and I saw how I
saw on people's faces sort of who they
were when they were struggling and it
was so beautiful to watch people
confront their desire to finish with
their bodies reluctance and it was it
was beautiful and then to watch how so
often one of the ways they did it was
people showed up to help them and it was
when I first started talking to ultra
athletes people were not talking about
interdependence it was like later
conversations that was the thing that I
found so beautiful is because from the
outside it looks like something that
people are doing only to prove that
they're tough and I can do it by myself
and of course you are doing it yourself
but most people aren't doing it by
themselves and that was so beautiful
when I realized okay this is this is
like the most beautiful display of human
inner strength and interdependence at
the same time yeah I mean that that
that's a very astute observation because
it is a very individualistic pursuit on
paper it's also this beautiful soul
journey you know there's a there's a
there's a soulful aspect to the
ultra-endurance community that's that's
really beautiful and I think unique
because people they're not getting into
it because there's prize money and
they're gonna become a professional and
make money like there there's something
that is calling them towards this
because there's something inside
themselves that needs reconciliation or
there's some answer that they're trying
to find for themselves and in that way
it's almost like in ascetic spiritual
practice
right like flogging yourself or
something you're like Oh marathon monks
yeah exactly exactly what you talked
about in the book as well where we're
you know by virtue of tackling this
challenge and seeing it through you will
have some form of transcendent
experience and will be changed as a
result but as you point out it is a very
collective experience and there is a
level of cooperation that you don't see
in other you know quote-unquote
individual team individual sports the
athletes you know all want to do their
best and there is a competitive aspect
to it of course but everybody's helping
each other and you know a lot of people
don't realize that most of these races
you have to bring your own crew
and these you're very dependent and
reliant upon these people in order to
finish and the crews will also help
other athletes when they're in need and
the athletes will help each other when
they're in need like when I did all
traumatic broke my pedal I got a brand
new pedal from a crew member of a
competing at like this goes on all the
time you know and that I think just
makes it this beautiful kind of
collective celebration where a group of
people have gotten together and created
this social contract that they're gonna
do this really hard thing together and
they're gonna be mutually supportive in
the doing of it yeah and so you know I
believe that that's one of the things
that real stress can bring out in us as
humans that was one of the core ideas
and my
his work and so that was when I saw that
that was playing out in the ultra world
that I was you know that was wonderful
to see but I also believe like that's
part of who we are and it brings it out
of us because that's part of our human
nature yeah and it's that perfect kind
of stressful situation where people
really have resources and when you're in
a very stressful situation and you know
you there's something you can do
that's sort of what humans do we rise up
and me we live one yeah and there's
nothing more elevating than real I
realizing that you have more potential
and capacity than you originally realize
that's incredibly empowering and on the
an idea of your previous work and stress
the core idea is basically please
correct me if I'm wrong that that you
know look stress is bad but it's our
relationship with stress that's most
critical and how it impacts us and when
we think about stress in a healthier way
it doesn't have the deleterious impact
that it would have otherwise and you
know movement sports ultra-endurance
whatever we're inviting a certain level
of stress into our lives to challenge
ourselves and as a result of grappling
with that we create you know what Susan
David would call emotional resilience
right so I you know like how does your
thoughts on stress and your work in that
field kind of intersect with her ideas
on similar terrain yeah I think one of
the things that she points out too is
the importance of welcoming and
embracing often the emotions that we
think we don't want and stress is just
part of that of those you know I really
think about the way that I think about
stress is it's what arises in your mind
in your body when something that you
care about is at stake and it also it
can push every button in our human
nature so stress can bring out the worst
in US and it can bring out the best in
us and that's true for everybody because
we have all these different competing
instincts and so you know what I'm
encouraging people to do is think how do
I build a stress response repertoire
that's really consistent with my values
and the stress in my life so that the
instincts that get triggered by stress
are
to become aggressive and hostile if
that's not appropriate or you know my
default might be become paralyzed and
withdrawal very human instincts but what
happens when we acknowledge that stress
can also activate the instinct to ask
for help can activate the instinct to
make meaning out of things that feel out
of our control or meaningless that it
can activate the instinct to learn and
grow to rise to the challenge and it's
about coming to terms with a reality so
that you can make a more conscious
choice about how you engage with that
reality there's a real sense of I think
like practicality and being strategic
and too often I think when we talk about
stress we're looking for a way to change
our inner experience because we're
afraid of the inner experience or we
have been told that the inner experience
is always toxic so if you're having a
stressful state it must be killing your
brain cells and destroying your immune
system and giving you a heart attack and
so we look for the thing that will
change the inner experience the fastest
rather than think well maybe I'm feeling
stressed because I care and maybe it
would be good for my happiness and my
health to engage with what I care about
rather than look for the quickest way to
shut off this signal mm-hmm have any of
your thoughts on stress or willpower
changed as a result of this deep dive
into movement or they just confirm or
affirm what you've always been talking
about some of my my thinking has changed
over the years I'm trying to think if if
writing this book led to any changes I
think the thing that I mean so the the
fundamental paradox that all my work
tries to grapple with is that human
beings have nature for good and for bad
and you know for helping and destruction
I think that's fundamentally true and
the science is always pointing in that
direction and so my work has always been
okay so you need to get to know the
destructive impulses in order to
strengthen the positive impulses and I
feel like this was the first book I
wrote where by far
what I was being confronted with was the
good in human nature and all my past
work I feel like there was at least sort
of an even balance the destructive
nature and the the you know pro-social
and positive nature and that to me it
gave me a lot of hope I feel like I
needed it at that time I just I feel
like everywhere I looked I was seeing
the good in human nature and that
movement somehow allows us to access
that I don't know that it changed my
thinking but it changed my perspective
yeah I felt like this this book and the
science pushes me to be more optimistic
about human nature than my that's a
tendency yeah yeah
how does competition play into this
because we you know if we talk about
movement a subset of movement is sports
sports being inherently competitive
there has to be healthy aspects yeah to
this but also unhealthy aspects yes and
I think so competition is a major human
Drive and there's a lot of psychological
benefits to it so when people tell me
that they love competition like my
sister is more like this and these like
one of our fundamental differences she
loves to compete she loves to improve
she loves mastery and I just sort of I
don't know that doesn't motivate me like
at all so I think the the really healthy
positive size of competition one is if
you're competing as a team or with a
group and the tremendous bonds and what
you learn from cooperating in order to
compete that that that seems like that
has tremendous benefits and that even if
you look at like children who or
teenagers who are engaged in different
types of sports uh-huh it looks like
there are more psychological benefits to
being involved in team sports than
individual competitive sports because
there can often be so much pressure on
the individual with you know to be the
best without some of those other social
forces that come into play when you're
working with others mm-hmm and I think
the other thing that's so helpful and
healthy about competition is when it's
really more about mastery that that you
have a sense of setting goals and moving
or them and that they are personally
meaningful and you sent yourself as
somebody who can set goals that are
difficult and work toward them and meet
them I thought a whole chapter about
overcoming obstacles and the very
definition of hope is to have a goal
that's meaningful to believe you have
the resources to meet it and there are
steps you can take and I think there are
forms of competitive movement that will
really allow you to access that that
whole experience of hope right yeah I
think that that's definitely the case
and you know I found my relationship to
competition like evolving like now I you
know used to be very competitive I'm
less competitive now and now it really
is more about the purity of the movement
that brings me joy and less about how
that measures up against other people
but the barometer is really internal
it's like how am i measuring up to the
standard that I set for myself and the
person that I want to be yeah yeah
that's that's what I feel like my inner
metric is too often I'm feeling like
this either has impact or it doesn't and
that there's less of a comparison like
I'm not really comparing my present self
to my past self like I don't have to get
better and I'm definitely not comparing
myself as much to other people like I
have to be better then but I'm very
closely attuned to did this thing I did
did it have any positive impact and
there's you know can be real sense of
failure around that but if that's less
competition then this kind of drilling
into performance that's consistent with
your values with everything that you
know about psychiatry and psychology and
human behavior what do you make of you
know this kind of cultural trend where
kids you know don't keep score at the
soccer games and everybody's a winner
and everybody gets a medal like you know
we've kind of recalibrated our
relationship to movement with young
people in a way that has stripped it
away of like any kind of peril or threat
I suppose yeah so you know how kids now
we're saying okay boomer when yeah I
know yeah I was just reading your ties
those great Taylor the Reds right so I
will tell you
one of the one of the gifts of teaching
at a university uh-huh is you see
cultural changes so one of the things
the goals that I've set for myself is to
be as open minded as I can when I see
cultural change is happening that my
instinct is to criticize them or to
think well that's not gonna have the
consequences you think it's going to
have so you know that's one of those
things where initiatives like Oh
participation trophy you can you can see
how things can go wrong and one of the
things I'm trying very hard to do is to
trust in the evolution of culture and
that if particularly if young people are
telling me something is good and
meaningful that I actually I'm gonna
trust that they are probably more right
about it than I am
so I I kind of I don't have a lot of
mixed thoughts about that I'm not sure
that there's a ton of science I don't
want to stand on either way so I'm gonna
default to a kind of open-minded
willingness to tolerate changes in our
culture that kind of go against how I
was raised
okay boomer yes well that's what I don't
want them to say to me we should explain
for people that are listening you don't
know what that means it's kind of a a
retort to you know older people's
opinions about exactly but it's got to
be interesting to you know be amongst so
many young people all the time it forces
you to change all the time that's the
other great gift is like you know you
got to stay with the program or you're
gonna get passed by and so so many
things you have to wonder you need a
challenge by like relationship to
technology or like what do you see on
the daily that doesn't not so he
triggers you but you're like wow look at
that that's so different having to be
really mindful about things like so when
I first started making PowerPoint not
even PowerPoint so back in the day what
are those things called transparencies
when we would give like public science
talks right
you'd have to win out your transparency
over heads yes nobody was thinking if
you're gonna use an image of a human
being to go along with you
like it says anger and you're gonna show
an angry face nobody thought doesn't
matter who you pick like in terms of
stereotypes out who's allowed to be
angry and who's not or or who's a more
fully human and now like that's such a
part of my work is thinking what images
I might choose and what language am i
choosing that that these choices that
early on in my academic career people
treated like they had no consequence
because the people making those choices
weren't really aware of the consequences
so I feel like that's one of the things
I'm always trying to deepen and learn
from is that there's probably
consequences to everything that I'm
doing and to make more conscious choices
about things that will improve my
students learning experience or that
will not create unnecessary harm just
because I don't know that what I'm doing
matters right is there anything though
where you're just really struggling to
get on board with tik-tok hey I'm
finally on Instagram is the one that I
have not signed up for it but you know I
feel like I would probably love it if I
could understand it yeah yeah never seen
is very dance and movement or you know I
think with the book tour you know about
to unfold here you're gonna have to get
on board I will
yeah cool well what what was what was
the most surprising thing you know I
feel like you have this robust you know
lifelong history and love affair with
movement so you had to have gone into
this with a certain sense of what to
expect as you dope into the research so
what it was there anything that
surprised you or defied your intuition I
was surprised by how easy it was to find
people who had never been given
permission to talk about why they loved
movement and how happy it made people to
be able to say I love my sneakers or
swimming is so important to me that I
kind of thought like I was a freak for
loving movement as much as I did and
then I've never had such a positive
response to anything I've ever asked the
public or on social media or friends and
family give people a chance and they
will tell you these amazing stories so
maybe that I don't know if that's the
most interesting answer but that's the
mode
- answer like the when I ask people
about there's this idea called the
pleasure gloss where when you do
something that's really enjoyable you
start to associate all of the sensations
of that that experience they become they
become insanely pleasurable even if at
first they didn't mean anything to you
like smells and sounds and when I ask
people do you have a pleasure gloss like
is that a real thing and people were
like oh my gosh I love the smell of my
yoga mat or oh the sound of my petals my
putting my cycling shoe right-clicking
it into the pedal is like dopamine rush
like nothing else and and when I ask
people is there a movement you've done
that was meaningful to you like you
never thought you could do it you have
like a movement story it was flooded
with stories like the woman who learned
how to swim when she was close to 50 and
she passed her swim test or you know the
woman the first time that she could do a
real push-up and there's the person who
learned how to hula-hoop in a non
dominant direction and this was like a
milestone moment in her life I was
shocked by how many people I knew I knew
personally and I didn't know any of
their movement stories and that it was
like there that people had them it's
cool we're we're in the midst of kind of
an amazing moment culturally with
respect to the explosion of interest in
movement you know it wasn't that long
ago that that you know jogging was seen
as a weird thing and now there's you
know bazillion people run marathons
every year and and that's not enough so
the ultra endurance community is blowing
up and we have these tough mudders and
the Spartan races and all these very
unique challenges that are compelling us
to you know go out venture outside the
cubicle and and test ourselves in a very
tactile way so how do you - what do you
attribute that like why why nallett why
are so many people like who wants to go
get electrocuted and crawl in the mud
and you know be freezing cold
I don't why are we appreciated yeah why
are so many people drawn to that now you
know I don't as a part of me wants to
pull back from the premise almost like
is that really the case I don't ask
no if you look sort of anthropologically
or you go to you know societies in the
near past that don't look like our
modern society people are living very
embodied lives celebration food
production competition with with other
communities everything is so fully
embodied you know I thought is I don't
know that the desire for this is so
different but maybe we've lost a lot of
opportunities to feel fully embodied in
our roles and our relationships and our
work that it's about restoring a sense
of our full humanity that if you aren't
using your body to do things that are
difficult and to celebrate life and to
connect with other people you're not
fully alive and maybe people are
recognizing that I don't know yeah I
mean I think that affirms the premise in
the sense that our lives have become
insulated and hermetically sealed we're
in our homes and in our cars and we're
riding elevators and we're in offices
with fluorescent lighting and we barely
even go outside let alone connect with
nature or our neighbors in any kind of
meaningful way anymore and that innate
human desire has been repressed to such
an extent that it it's you know it's
it's finally like needs a it needs an
outlet right so this is what we're
seeing people going out of their way to
bring this kind of movement and stress
into their lives because it speaks so
profoundly to what it is to be human or
to have a human experience you know and
that it reminds me of something that a
woman I spoke to when I was asking her
why she loved rowing and she said that
it brings out the best in humanity and I
think that that a lot of the people I
spoke to they said something like that
as well that the form of movement they
were drawn to they felt like it was not
only bringing out the best in them but
it was allowing them to see the best and
others too I think that there's a lot of
interest right now in these collective
training experiences or elective
movement experiences and I think that
like I certainly know that for me it is
very healing to see
the best than others and there's a lot
in our society now that Prime's us to
see the worse than others so that may
also be an antidote that right yeah
that's super interesting that's super in
yeah because media is all funneled
towards trying to you know basically
create these chasms between us and and
even if you were to watch like feel-good
media it's different when you when you
see like the feel-good news clip while
you're scrolling through whatever social
media versus being in an actual room
with people or you know where you can
smell them like there's something about
the the co-present embodied experience
that's different than the little
psychological uplift you might get yeah
I mean if I do yoga in my house that's a
very different experience than going to
a yoga class where were even if we're
not necessarily talking to each other
there is this consensual activity that
we're all engaging in together and
there's something that creates like a
unity or a congealing effect with the
group that you can't really put your
finger on or or articulate what that is
but it's very very real you know yeah
it's very real or even if I'm running
with a group of people that I don't know
like there is truth to that for sure
and I'm wondering you talked a little
bit about this in the book whether like
this cooperative kind of byproduct of
movement or the community building that
it engenders if that works in a visual
reality setting as well because we've
got peloton and we have these kind of
virtual communities around me did you go
bot I thought John go bot that the drone
that that follows you while you run
after those hysterical so is there a
know that people loved it they were like
yes I want a drone that watches the
target on my chest and runs with me so I
mean we're so things like really want
connection yeah so I don't know I have
tried I mean your sister must have
thoughts on this oh yeah I think she
would say probably know also I mean even
so four people don't know you know she
she has designed a number of games and
an alternate reality experiences and one
of the
strengths of most of her games and
interactive experiences is they take
place in the real world and they force
you to interact with other people
including the people in your life so my
guess is that she would not be like
totally in love with technology that
allows you to simulate social connection
rather than experience it right but what
about like peloton is a great example
like you're it's it's simulated but it's
also real
it's just displaced yeah in terms of I
think so I've had so many people ask me
about peloton I think they have a great
model and that it's probably primarily
not for people who like the medicine
they need is the group experience and a
lot of what they're doing is based on
music and how it feels to do something
hard and to be witnessed in a certain
way that doesn't have to be like a
closed focus you know you're having a
collective experience in which there's a
sense that that it's almost like a
mirror like you see yourself as having
done something really hard and the
soundtrack helps and the teacher helps
in the fact that it's often a live
shared experience helps but I think that
particular medicine is more about how
you feel about yourself and how you feel
about other people and again with
finding the joy of movement it's about
finding the medicine you need rather
than thinking you have to do it all
right get everything well music is a big
deal I learned a lot you I mean again
this is you have like almost an entire
chapter devoted to the impact of music
and movement yes an entire chapter I
could have written a whole book yes I
mean music Tommy's a little bit yeah
it's I like when I go out I either use
nothing because I just want to treat it
like a mindfulness practice or I'll
listen to audiobooks or podcasts because
it's almost like that's that's a way of
bringing a virtual community or
something to engage me a little actually
well I'm going and I'll only use music
for like the end or whatever but I can't
listen to music like for extended
periods of time like I need bursts of it
when I'm feeling like my motivation is
waning or I want to finish strong or
something like that that's funny that's
exactly what when I talk to someone who
leads work songs
in a farming community that was exactly
what he said that you use music when you
really need it when you're exhausted
when you're bored you need that extra
verse of motivation so it makes me think
that part of how humans have always used
music is not like this constant
soundtrack but that music brings an
extra kind of energy and motivation to
support us when we're reaching a moment
where it's more difficult and actually
the music sports psychologists I spoke
to said something very similar to that
like you you don't need an amazing
playlist for every aspect of your
physical training it's these you figure
out what the right moments are and the
song that will put you in the right
mindset or help you do something even
even more difficult more powerful but um
so the way I think about music is that's
actually not how I think about music
because so human beings our brains seem
to be wired to hear music as an
invitation to move
that's almost everybody so when you hear
music particularly music with a strong
beat that you like it activates the
whole motor loop of the brain it Prime's
you to move and when you move to music
you get this a little bit of an
endorphin rush and a dopamine rush that
feels good and what I've observed in
myself is that there's this other side
part of it which is where the lyrics and
the the key that the music is in all
these different qualities of music also
make you feel a certain way they bring
out an emotion or an aspect of your
identity mm-hmm and for me when those
two merged it's like nothing else to get
the endorphin rush of moving to the beat
of music while the lyrics are making me
feel a certain way about life and myself
there isn't like no greater high that I
get from from like anything and I think
not everyone is as I've talked about
genetic tendencies I mean that's deep in
me that is like a defining part of my
nature is nothing lights me up like
moving to music and so that's like how I
Center all the classes that I teach but
for other people it may just be that you
have the the normal human brain which
will experience music as a ergogenic it
will help you work harder it will reduce
pain it will help you connect with
others and you use it strategically
but um you know there's this other
aspect that that really is uh it's a
trip yeah it's also very sense memory
evocative right like you can hear a song
you haven't heard in a long time and you
can it'll just spring to mind like
something very vivid you know I don't
know what it I guess it's similar to
like I like the smell of my yoga mat
like there's a I don't know it's
something that that happens
biochemically or neurologically that can
root you in a past experience or trigger
a memory that can empower you in a
certain way and there's certain songs
that you just will go to time and time
again for that purpose yeah and I think
that because we listen to music with our
whole bodies that those memories feel
more embodied that that somehow we have
access to it in a way that feels more
visceral as you say why is it I don't
know if you know anything about this but
why is it that the music that we tend to
go back to time and time again
throughout our lives is music that was
imprinted on our on our brains like at a
certain age like you know I know that
like like you know like REM will always
be my favorite band doesn't matter you
know lesson yeah because when I was 16
or whatever I discovered it and I fell
in love with it and I still will go back
and listen to those albums time and time
again no matter what is happening in
terms of music outside of that I mean
there is research on this that because
we tend to have more emotionally like
peak experiences or intense experiences
and also we're busy trying to define
ourselves young people tend to use music
as a way of building identity so what
you listen to at that time you're gonna
have more like rich emotions that get
linked or often young people regulate
their emotions with music so they're
feeling you know more like chaos and
they listen to a song and so you're just
building a different intensity of memory
and also because that's such a period of
time where you're trying to figure out
who you are that that music will remind
you of both the intensity of that
process and also how you feel about
yourself and who you are I will say that
one of the things that I work very well
I don't really have to work hard at it
but I'm very committed to is staying in
love with popular music it's like a gift
to myself
uh-huh so that
I have now 42 years of musical memories
that are distinct and I feel like like
I'm gonna try to stay with that as long
as I can to keep building these musical
memories so that it's like it's your
chest expanding your repertoire for
nostalgia and sense of self and joy and
you could state you stay current with it
yeah and I say curtain you know so I was
saying to um some other women who teach
group fitness who some of the women that
I teach are on the young end in their
60s and then significantly older and are
saying to these other women who are my
age that right now their favorite song
is a lizzo track and they didn't believe
me and I was like of course you you just
have to share it with them and give them
an embodied experience of it who's not
gonna fall in love with Liz oh so I
always thought that I would always be
hip to like whatever was happening in
the music culture I have a 16 year old
daughter right now and she's into like
the most intense rap and hip-hop and I
strike I have such a hard time trying to
connect with it it's like super gnarly
and it confuses me that she's so into it
because it kind of doesn't exactly
measure up with her sensibility but it's
definitely doing something for her and I
want to be on board because I want to
have that shared experience with her but
I found that's why she want to have it
as a shared expression oh she cares but
she gets in the car and she doesn't ask
like who's playing the music she just
turns it on and cranks it way up and I'm
like just imagine you know 20 30 years
from now how that's gonna be a cherished
memory yeah like that song come on and
you'll have this embodied memory and I'm
and I have that awareness and I'm still
like I just have you tried moving to it
maybe what you need to do is is get down
into the groove
I'm gonna try I'm gonna think about you
next time we're having that experience
well no it's about it's it's a
broadening your empathy I mean we didn't
even talk at all about my work in
compassion but well let's talk about it
we can yeah but I think that that
choosing to open yourself up to
different forms of music is it is an act
of broad empathy yeah probably does
allow us to connect more broadly with
with other people yeah and I think
compassion particularly self compassion
is a big part of movement right like
movement is an act of self compassion
that actually broadens your aperture to
be compassionate towards other human
beings yeah
and vice versa I mean it's one big
circle so I'm not somebody who believes
you have to love yourself before you can
love others I think you can love others
and not love yourself and that either
way if you strengthen sort of either
side it is possible to get to the other
if you sort of make a conscious effort
and I think movement is great because it
can allow you to do both you know I in
the book I talked about you know
communities where everyone has goals and
they're cheering one another on and
they're helping one another overcome
obstacles and then they also get cheered
on and they get supported by others I
think that one of the ways movement
helps with self compassion is it again
it's not a do-it-yourself project it's
not like you're alone you know taking
care of yourself by exercising part of
what makes it an act of self compassion
is put yourself in environments where
people are going to be happy to see you
put yourself in environments where
someone will help you out when you when
you need help that you start to practice
also opening to the compassion that's
available to you in ways that may seem
very small but actually are meaningful
to allow yourself to be open in that way
and and again to also you know at every
level to think about gratitude to your
body for what it can do and there are
many ways that it can can bring out yeah
receiving the compassion sometimes
that's hard it is I think that is the
you know self compassion is a very
trendy topic right now
mm-hmm and the one thing I think people
are missing is that self compassion
means you believe that
you yourself are deserving of compassion
and sometimes the source is you and you
can say nice things to yourself and you
can practice self-care but a big part of
self compassion is okay who else cares
about you and can you believe that other
people care about you and can you be
transparent about your suffering so that
they can help you that is less discussed
as a critical self compassionate skill
yeah and we sometimes turn self
compassion into this project like go
into your compassion closet don't be a
burden on anyone else you should be able
to deal with your own pain and suffering
by being self compassionate yeah but
when it comes to receiving that from
other people I mean you know the
instinct that I have is that that's
indulgent or it's burdensome to other
people right like why should I have to
involve them in my like you know project
of self efficacy yeah and that sort of
inner voice is not really any different
than the inner voice that might say you
know the voice of self criticism like
you are so dumb why did you do that
you'll never change that these are all
voices we have that are barriers to
compassion they aren't correct but they
are pervasive and I think that when you
know I mentioned that compassion is a
big circle and so to unlock self
compassion we often need to put
ourselves in the presence of compassion
that is not generated by ourselves like
we need to see other people helping
other people maybe we just need to be a
witness to compassion in the world
mm-hmm
we need to feel that we ourselves are
capable of helping others or caring for
others so that we sense ourselves as
having something of value that we and we
notice how good it feels so that we can
imagine if we let a friend or family
member help us maybe that feels good for
them too it's not a burden because we've
experienced that it's not a burden when
we care for someone we love and don't
want to suffer so there's there's um
it's almost like we don't want to get
too myopic about the one part of
compassion that is most critical and to
put ourselves in this big system of
compassion that is big
than ourselves but it leads ourselves I
got the super important it's something
that's been very difficult for me to
learn I know the way that I was raised
and maybe it's a generational thing or
just my personal experience but you know
it's sort of like you know check
yourself like don't bother other people
with your problems like solve it on your
own if you need to seek help fine but
don't go around you know like trying to
enlist all these other people and
whatever it is that you're trying to
work out within yourself yeah I mean
that was how I was raised - is
considered a virtue to not be a burden
and to just take care of it yourself
and I think that if there's a way to
honor some part of that impulse towards
agency and you know and autonomy while
at the same time recognizing how how
interdependent fundamentally independent
we are that that's just not how we work
as human beings you can't do it all
yourself and it would make other people
miserable can you imagine if nobody ever
dependent like nobody want to listen to
this podcast nobody cared if you got up
in the morning and we don't want that
existence either well it's it's an
illusion anyway we're all interdependent
and I think that we walk around you know
what you're talking about stories we
tell ourselves like we tell ourselves
that these other people that we
mythologize or look up to have done it
all on their own and that if we want to
measure up we have to do the same and
it's just it's a lie you know it's a lie
and I think it requires you have to
marshal courage in order to be
vulnerable but ultimately when you do
that you realize that that that that's
actually a strength and not a weakness
and you have to I think you have to do
it in order to realize or to overcome
that counter-programming
and to recognize that they aren't
inconsistent I mean when we were talking
about the ultra world and what I learned
from observing it was that there was no
there was no like ceiling effect the
inner strength was just up up up up up
and the interdependence was up up up a
mom and that's how people do incredible
things right it's not like if you accept
help you are weaker and not still
calling on the same inner resource
it's just but you didn't see that until
you dove into it deeply because on the
scooter I was too busy like looks like
these people are doing it on their own
yeah I didn't mean I didn't know
anything about it except you know the
occasional horror story that I might
like to see you know was it I didn't
even write about this in the book but I
did this whole interview process asking
people about their DNFs and I heard so
many incredible stories and I kind of
regret I didn't find a way to put that
in the book somewhere
but these amazing experiences people had
of failing at ultra-endurance events and
what they learned from it and why I was
meaningful and that was a fascinating
part of the psychology too because I
feel like that it also is it's such a
perfect analogy for life in what way and
in other words how they how they
grappled with you know quote-unquote
failure and used it yes
fuel better performances later or what
else no no no that it was a it felt like
a tremendous act of self compassion you
know one woman was talking about the the
moment of having to acknowledge that the
injury she had reactivated but she
literally couldn't finish and she was
going to accept that and still honor
everything she had done and and have a
sense of this as a meaningful journey
and you know another person talked about
choosing not to finish to help another
participant who was sick and couldn't
finish and that felt like the the best
decision she could make that she was now
a part of this other person's journey
right where that person wasn't alone in
it I know there's just there were lots
of interesting stories where you see how
people make meaning and find compassion
and self compassion even in a moment
that looks like objective failure and it
was again it I think it's part of if you
think the only thing you can like if you
think you have to keep getting better I
mean this is one of the I think mistakes
people make about movement is because
when we're younger we think it's about
mastery and always getting better buts
but you know in the book I talk about
the people with Parkinson's disease
we're taking dance classes at Juilliard
yeah they are not taking dance classes
at Juilliard to perform at Lincoln
Center
that they are there because that
movement allows them to access some some
joy and part of themselves and I feel
like the DNF somehow it was also
reflecting that part of movement that
you don't always have to get better you
don't if you could be getting
increasingly worse until like the people
in hospice care who are serving well how
do you define victory and success like
we can define these more broadly like
it's a huge victory for somebody to
sublimate their ego stop on the trail
help another person like that's a moment
of beautiful self-discovery that
certainly shouldn't be discounted and
you tell the story in the book of the
Olympic track and field athlete who
pulls the hamstring and his dad you know
the famous this dad goes down there and
helps them across the finish line and
that becomes a story that transcends
whoever won that race that day right and
I think you know the ultra world is you
know there's tons of those kinds of
stories there all right well let bring
the focus back on to new year's
resolutions and I think one thing that
happens with a lot of people is they're
faced with this decision of like I have
this goal I want to do this thing do I
just go whole hog all-in overnight or do
I take little bites out of this and and
do it slowly in a way that doesn't
completely you know upend my entire life
I'm mystified by people who believe
there's an answer to that question of
course it's hen you must get that
question every day and the thing is is
you start where you are and you do what
you can do and you do it in the way that
feels like the right way to do it for
you and whichever path you choose you
don't tell yourself that's it or I
failed like you know there there's some
people who will take the baby steps they
get that goal down to the tiny thing
they can do tomorrow and feel successful
and then they find that they don't
actually feel successful because they
don't see the benefit of it or it
doesn't have a deep meaning to them so
you should give yourself permission okay
you need to go harder on this what's the
version of this that when you finally
get to do it you're gonna feel like
that's a triumph and then you give
yourself as much time because you need
to to get to that point if you feel like
you want to go all-in and then you
find out a month later this is not
working the way you had intended that it
was a learning experience
I think people shouldn't believe that
there are these tricks to behavior
change that are beyond what your
intuition can lead you to if you are
clear about what you care about and
you're willing to experiment and not
give up the first time it doesn't go as
planned right
I think that's super wise I think that
these things are all about getting
caught up in some kind of future
tripping or tripping over you know
stories that we tell ourselves about the
past right and the truth is all we have
is what we're doing right now and I kind
of love the way 12-step does it it's
just like you don't have to like you
don't have to worry about whether you're
gonna stay sober for ten years like what
are you doing right now are you gonna
drink your pill is your head gonna hit
the pillow tonight are you gonna drink
before you go to sleep tonight
like that's all you got to worry about
right like those tiny imperceptible
things that in the grand scheme of
things seem small but actually are the
levers that move everything yeah I think
you know one example I often think about
so one of the most difficult things to
do is to quit smoking there are some
people who can do it cold turkey and
I've talked to people who they made that
decision and they just did it and for
whatever reason it worked for them it
was an aha moment but there's research
showing that if you can delay the first
cigarette of the day by five or ten
minutes that that increases your chance
of quitting
so like that seems that seems totally
possible delay the first cigarette by
five minutes mm-hmm and that's something
you could choose to do tomorrow and to
know that both of those are pathways to
the same place and you don't always know
at first which one's gonna work for you
but that and there's a million paths in
the middle that look like something else
yeah do you know dr. Judd brewer yes oh
I also I saw the interview that you did
oh you did yeah yeah he's not amazing
he's great and he talks about being
curious rather than like hard on you're
hard on yourself or making judgment
calls about these things like can you be
curious about that craving can you lean
into it and try
learn about yourself by virtue of it and
kind of suspend your judgments around it
that idea of surfing the urge is
something that when I talk to people
about what has been most useful that has
come out of this integration of science
and contemplative traditions of all the
ideas because that's a lot of the ideas
I talk about they sort of are merging of
both worlds and that idea gets mentioned
all the time this idea that you can have
an inner impulse that is telling you you
have to do this thing because that what
you're feeling right now is isn't you
cannot tolerate it you need to give in
or you need to say this thing that
you're thinking or you need to buy that
whatever it is that there's a process by
which you can pay attention to it trust
that it will not overwhelm you that you
can ride it out and that you can broaden
your attention to your values or your
goals I mean that it works for
everything it's not just you know
actually how it was studied for things
like cravings yeah
pay attention it's mindfulness really
all right so we got to round this up
here in a minute but I want to leave
people with some insights or perhaps a
little bit of a cheat sheet as they
begin to kind of map out their 2020
and I'm thinking about the person who is
sitting there saying I hear everything
you're saying but I just like when I
think about movement I just can't get my
head around it I've never moved my body
before every every instinct is telling
me that I can't do it or that it's not
agreeable with me so how do we could
y'all that individual into kind of
rejiggering how they they're thinking
about this so one approach is to think
about the forms of movement that most
reliably make people feel better and one
is to go outdoors would go for a walk if
you can walk or whatever that version is
for your body that is very likely to
have a positive effect and moving to
music is another one or to do something
that feels like play whether it's with
kids or an animal or you know in a sport
and or to do something with your body
that feels useful like gardening or some
sort of like labor that feels product
in the book I write about this one
community that that pairs exercise with
community service projects which is by
the way the only form of exercise that
my mother will do writes for some people
the movement has to have a purpose like
planting trees or something
yeah we're cleaning or helping people
yeah
so I feel like you know there are
certain things where just try like are
you so convinced that this will be
miserable I haven't have you tried going
out for a walk someplace that you can
have some fresh air
have you tried putting on a song you
love when nobody's watching and just see
what movement comes out of you that
there are these little experiments you
can do where because you're a human
being even if you have what looks like a
barrier even if you live with chronic
pain or you have a disability or you're
struggling with depression even in all
those contacts most people benefit from
simple forms of movement um the other
thing I would say which is that's like
the delay your cigarette you know by ten
minutes approach but I often will tell
people I got like what's the movement
that inspires you what's the thing you
said I could never do that
that if you rethought it and said well
maybe I could to to set that kind of
that that possibility of a new version
of you that you haven't expressed yet
but you you sense might be in you and to
do that thing because I feel like that's
where often it's taking that bolder step
of like I've never been a runner but
I've always admired runners or I danced
when I was younger and haven't danced in
three decades but but what would that
feel like to be free in that way again
to to go to the thing that feels like
you just want to be that person in
movement
uh-huh yeah it's beautifully put I think
another big part of it and you talk
about this in the book is is engendering
the community aspect of it like enlist a
friend or a buddy or create
accountability and and community around
this so that you're not doing it alone
and there and you have to report to
somebody like in a good way in a bad way
like if you don't show up they're gonna
give you [ __ ] but you know if you do
show up they're gonna be there and
you're gonna be with your friend yeah
and to know that when you move with
other people you
build community like that's the other
part of it too sometimes I'll tell
people if you show up somewhere and you
kind of like how it feels but nobody
smiled at you that first time or like
there wasn't you didn't feel like you
immediately belonged and you have all
these amazing connections that when you
show up over time one of the most
consistent things that happens is you
form communities so if there's a place
that you want to belong where movement
is available if you if you're looking to
build connections with particular
individuals so know that movement is one
of the best ways to do that and so you
can keep showing up and that you
actually will develop a network of
support around movement right in the
same way that your muscles change I mean
those weights it just it happens
so with this robust career and
experience in human behavior
evidence-based human you know science
fact you know human behavior what is the
thing that keeps tripping you up like
what's the frontier for you that you're
challenged by or that you're trying to
work through well so the thing that is
not new but the thing that is the most
ingrained in me that I grapple with
daily is um I just have a nervous system
and a temperament that is overwhelmed by
like life like you know anxiety is my
default state and that has been true
since I came out of the womb apparently
so I feel like it's not a new frontier
but certainly the things that I've been
drawn to are things that make me feel
braver about life that that interfere
with my instincts to withdrawal and shut
down the other thing that I've been
working with a lot lately so a few years
back I was in this period my life I was
living in both New York and Palo Alto
California and when you live in two
cities you really don't live in any city
and I felt the I felt the consequences
of not having daily like neighborhood
driven community and since now I'm
located only in Palo Alto the frontier
that I've been working on is trying to
just honor and rebuild those daily
neighborhood based connections
that turned out to be much more
important for my mental health than I
realized
so that's the that's like the frontier
and then if I were going to try to give
other people advice I'm just because
I've been yeah we haven't talked about
the one other passion in my life which
is animal rescue and adoption and if
other people are thinking about
something to do and they don't want to
exercise please adopt something I feel
like I really want to write a book about
the psychological and social benefits of
of having a relationship with animals
that's beautiful you should write a book
about that coming up next I teach a
course about your problems my books are
all based on courses I got to figure out
how to I don't know if the business
school at Stanford is gonna want you to
teach that class but who knows right
what are the classes that you're
teaching right now right now so the next
class I'm gonna teach at the Business
School is on communication and it is for
for researchers who want to learn how to
communicate their work both to the
public and then and also just in any
kind of setting mm-hmm super important
coming from the person who has 21
million views on their - is it up to
that now yeah it's really morning Wow
crazy yeah I do got to be one of the
most watched TED talks at this point it
is and I did not honestly didn't think
people were gonna see it why is that I
don't know I said we said the main Ted
stage sure wise but you know I gave that
talk in 2013 and right I don't know that
I really I just it felt lower stakes to
me than it turned out to be because um
well I just I didn't think that as many
people were gonna see it as did I didn't
do that whole process that most people
do like the intense preparation or like
hiring a coach and a stylist I just
treated it like it was based on a
lecture that I gave to my introduction
to psychology class at Stanford it was
like an excerpt from my psych one
lecture and I just sort of treated it
like that Wow well maybe that's why it
worked
yeah I don't know are you gonna do
another one I don't think so no that was
it unless they let me lead a movement
experience well that would be a cool
follow-up but you've got to be on the
road quite a bit doing talk I'm that
kind of thing yeah since it one of the
things I'm trying to do is less of that
to make the choice to not have to sub
one of my movement classes in order to
be on the road speaking to a crowd of
thousands of people I've decided right
now that that is values inconsistent for
me and to make the choice to stay local
right and where is your curiosity taking
you now I am reading something about the
answer that question for me is the the
science that I'm reading a lot of and I
am reading two types of science more
like when I get the Google Alerts I'm
more likely to click on all the
abstracts then I get Google Alerts for
so many different topics because you're
just on PubMed like all day yeah okay
one is the default mode I'm still
fascinated by that how the human brain
operates by default when left to its own
devices I've been fascinated by that for
years and the research on that I just I
feel like it's one of those areas where
every day there's something else
fascinating like now well the default
mode network is sort of like the new
microbiome what's talking about it they
weren't talking about even a couple of
years ago but now it keeps coming up a
lot so I think that's the other is
compassion because I'm still so
interested in how do we deepen and
broaden our compassion and there's just
a lot of research right now
a lot of it is practical and applied so
people who engage in helping and around
a lot of suffering how do they sustain
strong compassion that is not draining
and traumatizing there's a lot of
research right now whether it's in in
health care rescue workers or Social
Work well it's a big deal in animal
rescue oh yes yeah I mean I've talked to
gene Baur about this quite a bit like
how can you can't you can't sustain that
kind of work if you're overly
emotionally attached to the results of
it because you could never rescue as
many animals as neat rescue right just
do what you can that but I'm so the
organization that I volunteer with the
most their motto is save them all right
and so there's always that paradox like
you have the ultimate aspiration that's
that's you oft I know it's right it's a
huge challenge and so I feel like many
people who are driven by compassion have
that motto even if they don't know it
but I'm here to save them all and then
on that that you know day to day basis
you are confronted
by what Parker Palmer calls the tragic
gap there's your aspiration and there's
where you actually are and you're
staring into this chasm of the tragic
gap between reality and your aspirations
and so part of sustainable compassion is
figuring out how do you find a sense of
compassion satisfaction in the middle of
that tragic gap that would be a very
interesting book yeah you know I think
because there's a lot of you know people
who are activists or feel strongly about
certain things in certain ways who've
devoted their lives to causes and there
is a lot there's a there's a huge you
know sort of psychological downstream
you know kind of damage that comes with
that yeah cool well I love the book the
joy of movement you did an amazing job I
think is gonna help like a lot of people
so congratulations on this the full
title is the joy of movement how
exercise helps us find happiness hope
connection and courage and if you want
to hear the full story behind the
subtitle you break it all down on your
website and you have pictures and it's
very fun and you're easy to find on the
Internet as well just Kelly McGonigal
calm and act Kelly McGonigal on all the
problems to them yeah all that stuff and
I assume you're gonna do a big full
blown book tour extravaganza
I don't know cuz I also want to stay
local but I do have my first book event
planned in New York City where we are
going to have a little conversation and
then a movement experience and then a
dance party and I'm hoping that any
place I travel to we're gonna find a way
to connect people to communities of
movement where they are so that's my
goal
cool exciting so you'll put that up on
your website like your schedule and all
that kind of stuff
all right cool well thank you so much
Kelly appreciate talking to you awesome
come back and talk to me again I feel
like there's a lot more stuff we can
talk about so cool all right peace
[Music]